jahr in folge war das kann man wohl
sagen das ist ein spannender tag ist
bleibt ein spannender tag sie bleiben
für uns da vielen dank ihnen schon mal
nach berlin meine damen und herren eine
pressekonferenz ich gucke noch mal auf
die uhr die eine knappe
dreiviertelstunde herr dr hornig
gedauert hat eine dreiviertelstunde
pressekonferenz der csu nur normal für
klare prozedere etwa fünf prozent hat
die csu deutschlandweit geholt trügt der
eindruck dass hier der kleine wirklich
kleine juniorpartner innerhalb der
unionsfraktion den großen partner die
cdu vor sich hertreibt also ich glaube
das war gerade ein schlüsselmoment wenn
ich das alles richtig verfolgt habe also
laschet war gegen die wahl des
fraktionsvorsitzenden am heutigen tag
weil er sich praktisch erst absichern
wollte oder abwarten wollte ob er nicht
oppositionsführer werden kann als
parteichef gleichzeitig parteichef und
fraktionschef jetzt stellt sich die csu
hin und sagt nein wir werden heute
wählen damit ist für mich eigentlich
klar so zu sagen wenn etwas was das
laschet heute eigentlich gar nicht
gewählt werden kann er wollte das ja
nicht heute das nicht weil er weiß er
wird die wahl nicht gewinnen der
fraktion in der fraktion sind viele
seiner fraktion lasten ihm viele das
wahlergebnis an er hatte schon vorher
praktisch kein riesen rückhalt in der
fraktion als es um die kandidatenfrage
gegen das heißt aus meiner sicht führt
er das ding nicht gewinnen wenn es aber
jetzt trotzdem zum schwur kommt dann
wird er sicher nicht aufstellen so also
ich glaube er ist jetzt extrem
geschwächt durch diese entscheidung der
csu es ist ja erst mal nur eine
pressekonferenz gewesen aber es hieß ja
jetzt den ganzen tag schon dass sowohl
armin laschet als auch markus söder
mehrfach telefoniert haben versuchen sie
das doch mal bitte mir zu erklären also
beide telefonieren offenbar miteinander
sprechen immer wieder darüber wie können
wir die kuh vom eis bringen wie schaffen
wir es welchen fraktionsvorsitzenden für
wie lange heute abend vielleicht wählen
zu lassen und dann tritt der gleiche
markus söder vor die presse spricht eine
dreiviertelstunde und eigentlich alles
was er sagt ist eine zumindest halb
versteckte aber doch relativ offene
kritik auch an armin laschet wie geht
das zusammen also die csu und und da
haben eine eigene agenda das muss man
ganz ehrlich sagen also ist jetzt
praktisch die die freundliche mit einem
lachen und freundlich formulierte
abrechnung mit laschet ehrlicherweise
weil man nimmt jetzt in kauf dass er
nicht antritt und beschädigt ist oder
antritt und vollkommen beschädigt ist
und danach praktisch vom parteivorsitz
zurücktritt treten muss man hat zum
schluss gesagt also es wurde ja viel so
auf die stimmung so in koalition neuer
und das letzte mal die botschaft ist
doch eigentlich dass das läuft nicht
also es läuft nicht jetzt noch nicht am
markt zu konstruieren also ist die
absage auch an jamaika und damit auch
die absage an einen möglichen kanzler
laschet was sagen sie zu dem argument
von alexander dobrindt eben in der
pressekonferenz der sagt naja also nur
für sechs wochen jemand jetzt im
übergang zu wählen wir brauchen stabile
strukturen das ist grundsätzlicher
vollkommen richtig also da kann man
nichts gegen sagen aber die botschaft
ist ja eine andere laschet hat sich
hingestellt gestern und hat gesagt na ja
wir gucken mal vielleicht machen wir das
interesse sich eben um nicht schon jetzt
strukturen zu schaffen gegen die er
später nicht ankommt jetzt stellt sich
die briten und sagt dort genau das
werden wir machen wir werden hinterher
nicht wieder das austauschen das heißt
für dich ist der zug ist abgefahren
eventuell oppositionsführer im deutschen
bundestag zu werden er glaubt aber und
das könnte ja eben gerade auch die
demontage des armin laschet gewesen sein
lassen sie uns einmal kurz und darüber
sprechen wir gleich weiter aber meine
damen und herren da lassen uns doch gern
noch mal schauen die über diese zweifel
dann auch gleich intensiver sprechen an
armin laschet nicht nur aus der csu
sondern auch aus teilen der cdu
also meine damen und herren hinter den
kulissen wird er offenbar ordentlich
diskutiert alle möglichen
unterschiedlichen kreise der union
wollen offenbar unterschiedliches wenn
man so die information aus berlin die
wir auch über die nachrichtenagenturen
da bekommen richtig deutet was klar ist
ist dass es mehrere personen gerade seit
heute morgen gibt aus der union aus der
cdu die armin laschet indirekt oder
offen doch klar kritisieren ich nehme
noch mal zwei drei dinge hier mit volker
bouffier der er einen abschnitt
vertraute auch ist er sagt wir haben
keinen anspruch auf
regierungsverantwortung das ist das
gleiche rück lavieren von dem wie
zumindest viele medien armin laschet am
sonntag verstanden haben der chef der
jungen union also der jungen cdu
sozusagen tillmann kuba und sagt wir
haben die wahl verloren punkt und
schleswig holsteins ministerpräsident
dann die günther geht sogar weiter und
sagt er fordert eine personaldebatte das
ist sozusagen der überbau aus diesem
vormittag jetzt sind wir am nachmittag
und man hat das gefühl dieser zug hat
sich rasant seit heute morgen 9 uhr
weiter entwickelt hinzu und jetzt kommt
die frage einer möglichen ende von armin
laschet morgen früh ich glaube dass also
zug ist glaube ich das richtige schicht
worten ich muss ich muss an den martin
schulz zu bedenken bei martin schulz vor
vier jahren das war auch alles etwas
ungünstig dann weiter nach außenminister
werden und das ist jetzt eine ähnliche
situation ich glaube armin laschet hat
dass das gespür vielleicht am wahlabend
dachte er noch neuer da ist dieser
strohhalm an dem halte ich mich mal fest
vielleicht könnte ich doch noch was
werden aber das scheint jetzt gelaufen
zu sein und noch mal dass die csu
pressekonferenz gerade das signal war
glaube ich sehr klar dass die csu da
nicht mitmacht sie ist eine kleine
partei sind natürlich recht die schreibt
die große vor sich her das ist aber
nichts neues das hatten wir schon die
letzten monate und ich meine es schön
dass herr günther sagt wenn man ist
jetzt zeit für personalentscheidungen
auch das hatten wir die letzten monate
man muss jetzt mal weiter denken was die
nächsten tage passiert ich meinen armin
laschet ist der wahlverlierer okay er
ist auch der parteivorsitzende
wer wird denn der nachfolger als
parteivorsitzender das heißt das
spielchen beginnt von vorne die cdu ist
glaube ich ihm wirklich schweren zeiten
im moment wirklich schwere zeiten die
wie schwer werden können oder wo noch
hinführen können na gut ich meine wahl
niederlage ist nicht sehr schmeichelhaft
für eine staatspartei wie die cdu die
sozialen darauf gepolt ist eigentlich an
der regierung zu sein dass das besonders
hart
diese regeneration in der opposition von
der man immer spricht klammer auf die
der spd jetzt in der regierung gelungen
ist klammer zu das würde der partei
sicherlich guttun ehrlicherweise das
muss man sagen aber bis dahin wird das
jetzt erst mal noch mal richtig unruhig
und richtig rüttel ich werde bis dahin
alter mann 17 uhr haben wir die
fraktionssitzung und zwar der neuen
abgeordneten meine damen und herren und
der alten abgeordneten sind noch dabei
sein und eben auch von csu abgeordneter
werden dann armin laschet und markus
söder dabei seien beide werden
sicherlich reden wir haben viele namen
die auch über die nachrichtenagenturen
kommen die diskutiert werden die
möglicherweise auch für einen
fraktionsvorsitz in frage käme ralph
brinkhaus sowieso hat sich ganz klar
geäußert er will eine wahl für das
typische eine jahr also nicht nur für
die übergangszeit bis zu hin zu einer
möglichen neuen regierung dann haben wir
friedrich merz wir haben norbert röttgen
wir haben jens spahn armin laschet hat
seinen hund eigentlich bisher gar nicht
in den ring geworfen aber man fragt sich
doch was passiert eigentlich mit armin
laschet wenn er jetzt wie sie gerade
sagen zurücktritt möglicherweise morgen
früh in den nächsten tagen ist da heute
abend vielleicht schon ein fingerzeig
also ich sag mal stichwort friedrich
merz als fraktionschef und
dann möglicherweise auch als parteichef
naja die die situation ist jetzt sehr
ungewiss also dieser fraktionsvorsitz
der ist plötzlich in der bedeutung
extrem gestiegen weil er könnte jetzt
ein trittbrett zu macht sein und auch
wieder zum cdu-vorsitz laschet wird die
wahl als fraktionsvorsitzende dass meine
thesen sich jetzt mal wird sie nicht
gewinnen deswegen wird er sich scheuen
und wird dadurch noch schwächer sein
stattdessen kommt beispielsweise
friedrich merz der total knapp verloren
hat bei den parteivorsitz der sieht nun
die chance okay ich kannte
fraktionsvorsitzender werden um dann als
nächstes auch noch parteivorsitzender zu
werden das endgültig zu schaffen weil
die partei hat jetzt gelernt anders
schaffen uns nicht und so weiter und so
weiter ralph brinkhaus wäre etwas das
bauernopfer ehrlicherweise der
offensichtlich gute arbeit geleistet hat
aber der keine ambitionen auf den
parteivorsitz hat also da kommen jetzt
sozusagen die schwergewichte und werden
also bei märz in dem fall und werden ihn
wahrscheinlich zur seite schieben bei
sparen und röcken glaube ich
ehrlicherweise nicht dass die chancen
hätten auf den fraktionsvorsitz sondern
jetzt scheint es mit hat sich da um die
wurst zu gehen